قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في اي لحظه لتدمر
معها مؤسسات الجمهوريه الخامسه في فرنسا
ان توصلت الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح
نظام التقاعد المعارضه اكدت استمرارها في
اتباع كل الطرق لاسقاط قانون التقاعد ومعه
الحكومه بعد ان اخفق نوابها في الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه في حجب الثقه عن حكومه
اليزابيث حيث اعلن رئيس الجمعيه الوطنيه
البراون بفيت عن فشلها
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للتصويت بحجم الثقه هي
287 بما انه لم يتم الوصول الى الاغلبيه
المطلوبه فلم يتم اعتماد اقتراح سحب الثقه
اما المحاميه ماتيلد بانو من حزب فرنسا
الابيه فوصفت الحكومه بالميته
فقط الى تسعه اصوات لحجب الثقه وكسر هذه
الحكومه واصلاحها الحكومه ميته بالفعل في
اعين الشعب الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع
بالشرعيه اتهامات بالبؤس المعنوي والسياسي
وعدم امتلاك الشرعيه الشعبيه ولا النيابيه
يواجهها الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بات مستقبله
على المحاك اتهامات قد تدخل البلاد في
ازمه حكم هي الاولى في تاريخ فرنسا
مارينلو بان كان لها راي اخر حيث اتهمت
الرئيس ايمانويل
وبان سياسته ستساهم في تمزيق الدوله
الفرنسيه
صحيفه لوبينيون محسوبه على الليبراليين في
فرنسا اكدتنا الازمه قد تتفاقم والحكومه
ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره وهي تخوض معركه اصلاح
نظام التقاعد اما صحيفه المحسوبه على اقصى
اليسار فاشارت الى وضع لا يحت مل وحاله من
الانهيار في قواعد الحكومه الفرنسيه
مراقبون للتطورات الحاصله اكدوا ان
استعمال منطق القوه في تمرير قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد سيؤدي لاغراق البلاد في
المزيد من الفوضى